this canadian veteran recently returned
home to quebec after narrowly escaping
ukraine with his life
he was fighting in the dawn bass back in
april when his volunteer unit was
ambushed by a russian tank there was
this huge explosion and i saw the
shrapnels flying in front of me the
canadian sniper known as wally spent two
months in the battlefield where he also
got caught in a propaganda war the
russians are not sophisticated fighters
after providing interviews to western
journalists back in march wally's story
went viral russia responded first with
posts suggesting he'd been killed then
state media wrote that wally had
condemned ukraine's military as a
terrible disappointment full of chaos
looting and incompetence they pretty
much took a few words i did and deform
it just enough so it kind of makes sense
so it sounds like i'm terribly
disappointed which i'm not what he
actually said to a french newspaper was
that war itself is a disappointment
particularly for inexperienced western
volunteers who initially rushed to
ukraine looking for adventure
wally says the ukrainian soldiers he met
on the front line were anything but
disappointing i really do think
they are the most courageous soldier i
ever saw personally but those twisted
facts and misquotes were heavily
promoted online by a small army of
professional internet trolls like senja
klochkova
at the start of the war the russian
journalist went undercover inside a
russian troll factory a new operation
called cyber front z
when i was hired they told me this is a
temporary enterprise to support russia's
army in cyberspace klochova told global
news she says they used fake accounts
often with western names to post
comments on youtube and across social
media praising putin and condemning
those who oppose the war
she says the people in charge are linked
to this former now notorious troll
factory in saint petersburg which was
accused of meddling in the 2016 u.s
presidential election
the operation employed a hundred people
per shift she says they were paid a
thousand dollars a month and were
required to publish at least 200
comments every day those comments
pushing the kremlin's narrative that
russia is liberating ukraine from nazis
were then reinforced by russian state
media it's impossible to defeat russia
evgeny popov is one of russia's most
popular tv hosts he claims for example
that atrocities committed by russian
forces against ukrainian civilians in
bucha were fake russia
have no connections to those dead bodies
when asked for evidence he falsely
claimed that it took ukraine five days
to reveal civilians had been massacred
and that the victims were never
identified give us a name give us some
names give us a family global news and
other world media outlets have
identified many names of civilians
killed in bucha but a quick simple
online search also turns up articles
referencing those russian conspiracies a
testament to how effectively the kremlin
has flooded the internet with
disinformation burying the truth no
matter the cost jeff semple global news